um let's talk a little bit about uh
diversity in tech
uh since i think that uh it's been a
very interesting couple of months i've
literally had
[Music]
two or three investors call me and say
can you introduce me to a black founder
i can invest in
i'll just say it as simply as that
morgan is it
is it changing for you as a founder
who's black
and female are you finding people
reaching out and saying
hey i need to solve this problem in my
portfolio can i invest in your company
or can i support you in some way and
then how does that feel
as somebody who maybe was underestimated
slash
you know ignored previously by other vcs
um so a couple things i i think i have a
privilege that i have to acknowledge
which is i've already raised my series a
i've
already made it through a variety of
steps so i'm on the series b
track right um and so for me
um you know you don't just invest in a
series b
out of white guilt you know right you
gotta have numbers
yeah like we got serious numbers i have
a serious business
you know this is a like we're gonna
we're gonna keep it going
uh kind of a plan we've got pivot you
know etc
platform all the things so i think for
me
most people actually look at me and say
morgan we know that you are
connected in the space you advise
entrepreneurs you're an angel investor
we know that there are probably people
that you know that we can't see yet
because of our own blinders who should i
reach out to
who should we connect with and there's a
lot of noise there's a lot of new
organizations popping up there's a lot
of new funds popping up
um and so for
for me i've been just triaging like i'm
just a quarterback right now so
you know i send out my own little email
that says hey here's like five
black female founders who are raising
their seed
right now and have already raised x
amount and here's their
information and you're not going to find
this on a public database because
they're no one's putting those real
numbers out there right like i never no
i mean our our industry is opaque by
design people do not want to
post their roadmap anywhere what are the
organizations that you feel are making
the most impact and that people need to
know about
so in terms of discovery of
underrepresented founders
the two that i love the most that i
think have the widest reach around
america that don't have the kind of
exclusivity tone
that i think scares and and keeps so
many people out is one is founder gym
which focuses on underrepresented
founders and teaching them about vc and
if you should even raise vc
and if you are here's how you do it i
mean they bring all your kind of silicon
valley insiders in as coaches to do
kind of amas etc and that's 100 virtual
it's like 100 virtual and do they invest
or do they just mentor
no investment no equity it's a fee which
i actually think is more reasonable
oh okay cool so it's like just buying a
subscription to masterclass or something
you pay a fee exactly
it's online community yeah 50 bucks a
month 100 bucks a month 500 bucks a
month you have any idea
no it's expensive it would be more like
a virtual incubator got it okay
so i don't know how much did 500 cost me
like 150 000
or something so but take out some zeros
yeah perfect i i think that that is
a really important point because the
thing i hear
from black founders people of color
women
uh underestimated folks which is the
term i like best
underrepresented underestimated is
the where to start and do you want to
even meet me
is a blocker and you know jackie who
works with us here at launch she created
founder university with me and
she does one for underrepresented
founders i think you've spoken at it
actually or
um yeah i did and once we
did that and we had underrepresented
founders as a
exclusive thing the number of underwraps
remained founders
who contacted us went through the roof
because you signaled do you care
i remember when i first fundraised i
went and looked at all the other black
founders who'd fundraise and i looked at
all the vcs that had invested in them
and i made a list of those people
because i said
look if you're if you've invested in one
then you can at least
understand me slightly better than
somebody who has indicated that you
can't even invest
i'm a really black company you know so
i'm serving black people we're solving
black problems i've got a majority poc
staff a majority black woman leadership
team like
you know we're very black so if you
can't even invest in one black person
who's solving some random
non-black problem and is an enterprise
sas company that's like and this person
went to stanford or mit like whatever
they've got all the credentials
except for they're black if you can't
even invest in that guy
you're probably not going to invest in
me yeah it's
what's the other company you had another
one you said you oh and then one more
and this is most i have more for women
is actually already has been doing some
interesting thing and i know that
they've gotten
they've been they've gotten a lot of
mixed bags because they weren't super
diverse
when they first launched and there's a
lot of feedback present company included
about like you gotta you gotta up your
diversity like
you can't just do the white woman thing
but
i think that they've listened and made
some adjustments and so they're doing
these really cool programs and i just
have been
happy with the acceleration of all of
their work
and i think being a black female founder
is just such a unique
like part of the pie right it's already
like
less than two percent to women and then
even further
i mean i don't even know the number it's
got to be less than one percent it's
definitely not half of the
women are black no way so right that is
to me uh i love all rays and what
they've been doing and i'm sure there's
many groups that i'm
i'm missing out on so don't attack me on
twitter that's it i think it's a very
interesting point because
we were sitting here 10 years ago and
the conversation was why are there no
women fee
you know vcs and all of these vc firms
you know
i'm an angel investor slightly different
but vc firms were six
white guys and then they're like okay we
got to get a woman in here because
man does this team page look bad and
they're like
the big hack at that time was oh yeah
here's our partner
the marketing and comms partner and it
was like
right come on like can they write a
check and i was like no but they can get
you on cnbc
and i was like come on really like real
window dressing kind of stuff
but then they all of a sudden we saw
more female founder a more female
representation asian female
white female as you're saying yeah
latino i mean
you can't name ten black female uh vcs i
i could challenge most people they
probably couldn't name ten
uh monique woodward uh arlen hamilton
two yeah there's more
i know there's more keep going don't
tell me tell me because i i'm i'm prob
i'm not very good with names but i'm
just going down the list of people we've
had in the podcast recently
i mean there's tons of angels like
heather hiles um
she was i mean there's just i'm not
going to go into it yeah
i mean a lot of black male vcs too a lot
more i should say
when they have funds that they um so
they've they've raised 20 million
funds 15 30 50 100 250 million dollar
funds
i think the biggest a black woman has
raised is maybe 75 or 100
it is one of the final pieces of the
of the puzzle i think in terms of just
we have to get it done i mean you you
the fact that we're sitting here still
having this discussion it's 20 20 it's
just bizarre to me
yeah but whose problem is it to solve i
think if there's no one person's
responsibility that it is and i
you know i certainly do think it's like
white people have to
solve this to some extent i also started
my company because i was like i'm not
waiting for white people to solve my
problems
so we gotta get going on our end too
like
my friends who are founders need to exit
so they can just go be billionaires and
like let's just be the paypal mafia and
like do our own thing
like why i think that's like a great
insight as well alex you had something
to add
oh i was just gonna say on the on the
doing something part of this i i have a
list of vcs that i talk to
and um i've started just writing down
list of every black vc that i hear about
and i'm trying to expand my
entire roster people that i talk to for
stories for insight that i get on the
phone
with um and i'm just gonna i guess brute
force diversify it and try somewhat
harder to not be
i i had some diverse people on my list
but it was mostly white dudes and i just
decided that that wasn't okay and i
wasn't gonna try to do this by small
steps i was just gonna go
find everybody and try to get their
email address and start talking to them
and so i think that's the kind of thing
that will increase representation
stories and media and will have a
positive effect and
um i'm encouraged that i'm not alone and
trying to to be less bad about this
trying to be better and i think the last
thing i would say
is like um let's ask black people about
their businesses
you know like you know one thing i even
appreciate this conversation
we're not just sitting here talking
about black people all the time like
we're not just inviting me onto the show
to just talk about blackness like no why
like i can talk about a variety of
things i'm always going to represent
black people
from my voice that is my my lens of the
world
um and my company my community but at
the same time
let's also not just continue to
perpetuate it by then saying
oh we must have a black person on this
planet
like what is it like to be black and
it's like well why don't you ask them
like
why they're they've raised 10 million
dollars they're like wow how they grew
and scaled their team or like whatever
questions you ask everyone else
yeah that that is i think a super
important thing for people to keep in
mind because i hear that over and over
again
uh when we're interviewing people for
our accelerator which is like
wow you guys actually are interested in
our business and the details of our
business and
you not once did we ask you about like
hey what's it like to be a black female
founder you know it's like exactly tell
me about your customers
what's your lifetime value what's the
can you take me through the unit
economics
it's our job to increase and find more
founders
but we should be asking the same
questions right it should be the same
process
but you just ha we do internally is we
just hold ourselves to
we just didn't find enough people for
this class we you know when we're
talking about the accelerator
we really need to work harder to get
more people to apply
we have to go find people to apply we
have to go
let people know that you know we are
looking to make those investments and
now since we've got
a pretty decent track record it's not
exactly where i want it to be
but i mean i feel like we've made
massive progress in the last two years
now i'm getting vcs asking me like how
did you do it
and i'm like wow how did you but how'd
you get your deal for them like
do an event just for people who are
underrepresented
and watch the magic right like it
actually does work
the number one reason people told us was
oh
when you did an event for
underrepresented founders we knew that
you cared we knew that you were
like actually sincere whereas
coming to a you know a generic launch
festival event or tech crunches up how
do you know
that you're welcome right you got to
make it explicit people
um that's at least that's the the leak
in my balance
it's like you have to be explicit but
also don't diminish so
it's like you know i want to if you have
caviar at your event for white people i
want caviar at the black event
in fact add champagne like 100 yeah you
know so that's that's the other thing
it's like
people are making the diversity funds
i'm like okay but why like you
just invest out of the main [ __ ] why do
we need a separate but equal fund
like just i thought that was a weird
moment for andreessen horowitz as well
i think people misunderstood
misunderstood it was misunderstood i
misunderstood what nate was doing
because i saw everybody
all of a sudden start dunking on nate i
asked him to come on the pockets he said
he was too busy
i'd andreessen horses team was probably
like
nah no andreessen horowitz probably
going to listen to this and be like
morgan is too close to the people
and jason horowitz doesn't like me but
anyway i put that aside mark andreessen
specifically doesn't like me
mark can't decide he blocks me then he
follows me then he unfollows me
it's very weird but he's a weird dude
anyway uh or i should say quixotic
um but uh
nate i thought what nate was doing was
they're gonna be giving
like small uh grants to people
to kind of get started not venture
capital investments am i right
did you read up on that one i think that
they made a mistake announcing it in the
mix
because this is something that has been
on nate's heart and mind for quite some
time he had talked to me about this a
while ago
so um i think that was just a mistake
frankly and they obviously recognized
that mistake after the fact but it's too
late
and then two it's a donor advised fund
so it's a not for profit
it's not a venture fund venture fund so
that's completely different you know and
i don't think that was made clear i
think that
i do think people got caught up in the
hype of saying we're doing this cool
thing and so they wanted it to sound
sexy
and sound cool and sound like they were
really making an impact and it was like
but then you maybe overreached a little
bit and therefore
people called you out but in reality it
was actually just a donor advised fund
and they've probably already raised an
additional 10 million into it and it's
probably fine now
yeah that was such a weird moment to
watch people dunking
on somebody trying to who's a black man
who's trying to
help people get into the industry and
i'm like that's
why not hear him out it's so weird and
and
meanwhile there are funds just as big as
injuries in horowitz in firms
just as big as andreas and horowitz
who've done zero
zero right so somebody stan somebody
stands up and they're like i have an
idea like let's try to get more people
to start companies and give them grants
and do some cool stuff with this with
this donation advisor fund and instead
of
that they're like oh you have eight
billion under management you made a
billion dollars off of that that's what
i'm saying but this is twitter
like all these things that we're talking
about right now are all the attacks that
happened
on twitter and that's why i think it's
just whack you know
and and at the same time i think for for
our community of people who do want to
hold others accountable
let's shine that exact same light on all
the people who are still quiet
who have made no investments in black
founders at least andreessen horowitz
has
maven it has um yeah
the healthcare company escapes me right
now but like
they have black founders at their that
they've invested in and others don't